raus aus der scheiße user konzert in mit
dietmar wischmeyer
so genossen das wird ne verdammte
challenge euren klappstuhl verein wieder
in irgendetwas wählbares zu verwandeln
kann doch alles nicht wahr sein
die letzte positive meldung aus der spd
war eine schröder homestory in der
bunten übrigens in diesem bild hat
photoshop einen ex kanzler versteckt
kleiner tipp es ist die brünette links
frage wieso schafft es gerd schröder
noch lebensfreude auszustrahlen mit
seinen über 90 jahren
aber ihr als partei nicht ihr könnt doch
nicht jedes jahr einen neuen
vorsitzenden verraten
allein unter merkel hat die spd jetzt
schon sieben von denen durchgenudelt wo
sind die denn alle habt ihr die im
garten hinter dem willy-brandt-haus
verbuddelt und vor allem wie kann man
denn sigmar gabriel raus kegeln diesen
grundsympathischen man den charming bei
der spd warum kümmern sie sich nicht
darum dass sie das alles von alleine
wissen nichts von dem was sie sagen ist
richtig forscher sagen nee was ja auch
blödsinn ist wo ist die mit 25,7 prozent
ja sagen wenn du das wissen will sich
versucht nochmal ganz langsam
ja natürlich ist der gabriel ein nicht
mehr schulpfarrer boller kopf deswegen
ist er außenminister wen wollt ihr denn
sonst so putin schicken den schäfer
gümbel so einschnitte sich der jaguar
morgen zu den döner
nein er braucht mehr hiervon abteilung
attacke
angela merkel gekreuzt mit einem pitbull
und als welpe in der eifel ausgesetzt in
alles müsste jetzt durchprügeln als
vorsitzende und bloß nicht die basis
fragen
einmal durften die mitglieder den
spd-vorsitz bestimmen und da kam das
hier raus
die radelnde teppichfliesen mein tipp
bank endlich an euch wieder selber zu
mögen
keiner will dass höhere neuer neviges
genörgel niemand niemand von uns kauft
seine brötchen beim bäcker
wenn da die gesellen stehen und sagen
hut ab da der richtige tag drin ist das
wissen wir auch nicht und was mit
unserem chef los ist wissen wir auch
nicht
diese brötchen kaufst du nicht und du
lässt dir von so einer firma schon gar
nicht ein haus bauen
warum soll ich mir von meinem bäcker ein
haus bauen lassen egal am besten löst
euch auf und kommt unter neuem namen
zurück sowie der makro mit orange oder
auf deutsch marschieren so was lieben
die deutschen zumindest die im osten
beziehungsweise partie
den schleier